e aí galera sentimento naldo com vocês
como está ótima delícia primeiramente
agradecer a galera em fortaleza por mais
de 2.500 ingressos vendidos até agora o
show é amanhã dia 12 de dezembro às seis
horas da tarde no ceará ao ingresso
nesse site e no final do ano essa época
maravilhosa que deus nos dá em deus meu
ano maravilhoso em adorei inclusive
começa a crescer depois porque o negócio
aqui agradecer por esse ano foi
maravilhoso né porque as pessoas vão
chegar à final do ano e já começar a
minha meta para o próximo ano é fazer
isso não é a minha meta para o próximo
ano e foi essa que já o final do ano de
2015 a pessoa está tentando cumprir a
meta de 1995 ainda para quem faz meta
mais em si não dá conta nem final de ano
a pior coisa é não era passar na escola
porque natal e ano novo são épocas
festivas mas você só consegue fazer
épocas festivas se você não ficar em
recuperação não ficar em recuperação na
escola fica devendo a matéria na
faculdade ficou devendo a matéria na
faculdade já sabe como vai ser a sede
natal neto dando muito peso naquela
professora que parece um tiro mas eu já
tinha uma técnica para nunca fica de
recuperação que era o seguinte eu fazer
eu combinava eu e mais dois amigos cada
um isto dava um pedaço do tema da prova
que acontecerá três pontos foi tirar
três vou tirar três cada um chutava o
conhecimento ali na hora da prova e
portanto não tinha nove eu estudava uma
coisa da outra e o ambiente dá uma luta
só que a professora me a professora ela
não é boa não a percebe a tua felicidade
ela sente que você está seguro na prova
eu sabe que você não é inteligente não
porque está seguro porque está feliz
vamos acabar com a felicidade depois
enviado jorge outros lá pro fundo da
sala a ver com a vaca o outro canto da
fala
ó
tomou nunca abusou de professora que só
não passa curso e cinnamon assim o que o
deixa bem dizia assim ó enfim no meu
blog quer me fazer mal ao estupro mas
não me deixe de recuperação não cara meu
deus agora fica de recuperação já era
meu amigo secreto não vou fazer um amigo
secreto não eu não goste amigo secreto
que porque a gente dá um playstation 2 e
ganha uma caneta bic e por que
participar china lá todo mundo ganha
iphone transforme eu só pessoa justa eu
tenho que ganhar o meu exemplo e depois
o da presença da pessoa se eu tiver
comprado o playstation 3
aí a pessoa me dá uma blusa o que é que
eu faço eu escondo que vai ter três
bolas na cozinha pega o jogo de pano de
prato de dal pra ele assim se podem ser
justo na vida a vida tem que ser justa
eu vou o aniversário meu presente focar
eu como metade do bolo para compensar a
não gosta do final de ano porque bobinas
e na virada do ano no natal as pessoas
colocam ou passa em todo lugar
aí eu não gosto de uva passa né engorde
da paz
meu deus sei por que esse ódio de uva
passa só de roupas a loja de roupas na
ceia tem uma tigela de arroz normal ea
tigela de arroz com passas a pessoa tão
mal comida ela pega o arroz com passas e
fica tirando a paz e reclamando da pasta
vai tomar no roupas anbima não gosta não
comigo eu vou dizer uma coisa para vocês
as vezes que se desfaça de uva passa
para testar a humildade das pessoas que
tem gente que não gosta de ver a passar
eu odeio vou passar inmetro palco -
carne por comer carne por carne pouco
depois vai dançar no outro dia tá com
carneiro se eu fosse uma uva passa a
olhar de forma a roma nem comeu os toca
porque o tempo e criança e natal em
natal ou passa com a criança não como a
pessoa desenvolve um ódio de uma pasta
quando cresce quando é criança criança
inocente criança pega ou passa bota na
boca chega gargarejo criança que é mais
criança não liga pra presente amigo
secreto criança só roda seu presente ele
ganha uma tampinha e detergente
principais de trégua mas ia de bicicleta
e bota na tap da gente mas o upgrade e
brinca eu falei blade - mais uma blade
blade é de gente feliz agora brincar de
blade assim se faz é assim que faz natal
feliz gente feliz se diverte com
qualquer coisa qualquer jogo qualquer
besteira e tatá eu estou feliz com o
jogo até encontrei na internet que eu vi
no facebook as pessoas fazendo o que
você ganharia tanto bond companhia está
na saúde
testei pega vareta cada quatro rochas
legal que só acho que vou deixar o link
do jogo aqui na inscrição e se você
tiver gostar desse vídeo seria sabe
fazer é só clicar em gostei aqui no
youtube se inscrever no canal nunca
perdeu um vídeo novo gostou do vídeo ela
sabe fazer é só clicar em gosto aqui no
youtube e volta lá no meu facebook deu
porque o vídeo não sequei clique kurt e
marcar um amigo seu para assistir esse
vídeo também em 2007 é esse meu estado é
esse meu twitter é esse se você quiser
me seguir é só seguir aqui valeu é nóis
meu irmão pai eu falei maluco